now before we introduce mayor simmons
max tegmark is going to show a short
video yeah and continuing on where we
just heard from Susie and from you here
it's a we at the future life is you
really want to make it easy for people
to make their own decisions about what
they want to do so this website
responsible investing responsible invest
or that's that there's the app for that
so we talked about this morning and
there we don't want to decide for you
whether you should worry only about
warheads or only about delivery systems
or or whether you should support divest
only from part of the nucleus whatever
it's all up to you and go there you
click about on what you care about if
you feel that there's more information
you would like to exist that's not
easily available email me tag mark @
mit.edu and we'll try to put it up there
because we want to put the decision in
your hands you want to empower you all
okay and we heard from Susie Snyder that
you would like to see more attraction
here on this side of the Atlantic on
following the money and using that as a
tool to reduce the risk of nuclear war
and we have some very exciting news on
this front here and I want to just
preface it Barbie my by providing very
brief summary of some of the core ideas
we've heard so far in the conference
Justin physicist max tegmark here to
answer some questions hey max why should
I care about nuclear weapons because
we've learned that there are even more
dangerous than we first thought the
biggest threat from nukes isn't
explosions that killed millions of
people or radioactive fallout the kills
even more or even a high-altitude
electromagnetic pulse the causes mayhem
by frying the electrical grid and
electronics course a confident know the
biggest threat from nuclear weapons is a
global nuclear induced winter in which
the fires and smoke from as few as a few
thousand nukes the dark in the
atmosphere
to plunge earth into a planet-wide mini
ice age with year-round winter light
conditions this could cause a complete
collapse of the global food system and
apocalyptic unrest potentially killing
most of us 7 billion people on earth but
didn't we get rid of most nuclear
weapons when the Cold War ended well yes
and no when the Cold War ended the US
and Russia slashed their nuclear
arsenals but they still have about 7,000
nukes each which could allow either
country to create a nuclear winter on
its own even if the other doesn't
retaliate but why should I worry about a
nuclear winter when nobody in their
right mind would start a nuclear war
unfortunately an all-out nuclear assault
isn't as unlikely as you might think
because the most likely way for a
nuclear war to start isn't political
it's accidental for example the time
faulty computer chips in u.s. alarm
systems erroneously signaled incoming
Soviet missiles in the u.s. started to
prepare of a full-blown retaliation for
that time when Russian satellites
mistook an unusual glint of sunlight on
clouds for incoming American missiles
and an officer averted retaliation just
by ignoring the alarm on gut instinct
where the time after the Cold War ended
when Russian radar systems thought a
Norwegian scientific market was an
American nuclear missile and almost
launched their missiles in retaliation
you know these close calls keep
happening and sooner or later our luck
is gonna run out and an entire nuclear
arsenal is gonna be launched
accidentally isn't getting rid of nukes
and national security threat though well
no cuz it's pretty clear that a country
only needs a small number of nuclear
weapons to have an effective deterrent
against nuclear attacks and anymore as
much of a national security threat to
the nation that owns them as to the rest
of the planet so given the risks of
accidental nuclear war a nuclear winter
it's stupid dangerous and irresponsible
for any country on Earth to have more
nuclear weapons that it needs for
deterrence if we continue avoiding
excessive nuclear arsenals winter is
coming
okay I have one more question why should
I spend my time worrying about nukes
when there's nothing I can do about them
actually there is something you can do
the nuclear arms race isn't driven
entirely by security interests money
drive 22 and politicians like to act
tough and in a time when they really
should be downgrading the US and Russian
government's are both playing to upgrade
their Arsenal's at a huge cost and who
does that money go too well about two
percent of the SP 500 companies are
involved the nuclear weapons production
and while you can't stop paying taxes
you can help stigmatize nuclear arms
race by divesting from companies that
produce nuclear weapons i'll give you a
link that you can put in the video
description to a site that helps you do
just that all right thank you max and
thanks to the future of life Institute
for their support and help reducing this
video individuals we can also try to do
them with or the organizations that were
involved in and it's one thing to talk
the talk it's another thing to walk the
walk and with that I want to turn it
over to one of my favorite people on
this planet mayor Simmons
let's do this in stock all right can
everyone hear me for okay thanks so it's
really first of all let me just say it's
really been a pleasure to be here and it
was great to have the opportunity so to
open up this conference and I think it's
good we touch to start and finish on the
very same wig kind of upbeat because I I
had I stayed Jonathan write that down
there were 12 things to do today but I
stayed here and I'm glad I did because I
got a lot of good information I've met
some very wonderful people and even
though there were times I actually felt
hopeless I also felt hopeful you know
something you said Susie he said we have
agency and we have power and we can all
do something about the nuclear bomb that
will make us feel good so let me just
preface by a quote that I love it really
kind of gets me going it since my market
me and she says never doubt that a small
group of thoughtful committed citizens
can change the world indeed it's the
only thing that ever has so this very
small group of citizens Lucas Perry and
professional and my good now my very
good friend Mac professor max tegmark
came into my office a couple of months
ago and said you know that we can make a
difference by just doing this one little
thing and then they talked me through it
and I was first of all amazed I was
appalled and a bit incredulous and I
said well what can we did how do I walk
the walk so so Susie I want to be the
gold standard policy maker
I want Cambridge to be the gold standard
policy makers because each of us do have
a role of responsibility and each of us
can do something so based on the with
information that that Lucas and I'm very
party back to say very proud the
research that he didn't brought to my
office with Professor tegmark so that I
wrote with their assistant this policy
order I would like to share it with you
and it reads as follows says whereas
nations across the globe still maintain
over 15,000 nuclear weapon some of which
are hundreds of times more powerful than
those that obliterated Hiroshima and
Nagasaki and the detonation of even a
small fraction of these weapons could
create a decade-long nuclear winter that
could destroy most of Earth's population
and whereas the United States has plans
to invest roughly one trillion dollars
over the coming decades to upgrade its
nuclear arsenal with which many experts
believe actually increases the risk of
nuclear proliferation nuclear terrorism
and accidental nuclear war and whereas
in a period where federal funds are
desperately needed in communities like
Cambridge and others in order to build
affordable housing improve public
transportation develop strategy to
sustainable energy sources our tax
dollars are being diverted to and wasted
on nuclear weapons upgrades that would
make us less safe and whereas investing
in companies producing nuclear weapons
implicitly support this misdirection of
our tax dollars and we're as socially
responsible mutual funds and other
investment vehicles are available and
accurately match the current asset mix
of the city of Cambridge retirement fund
which excluding nuclear weapons produces
and whereas the city of Cambridge is
already on record in supporting the
evolution abolition excuse me of nuclear
weapons opposing the development of new
nuclear weapons in calling on President
Obama to lead the nuclear disarmament
effort now they're being ordered that
this
the Council formally goes on record and
opposing investing funds from the
Cambridge retirement system in any
entities that are involved in or support
the production of or upgrading of
nuclear weapon systems and be it further
ordered that the city manager be and
hereby is requested to work with
Cambridge peace Commissioner and other
appropriate city staff to organise an
informal form on possibilities for
Cambridge individuals and institutions
to divest their pension funds from
investments in nuclear weapon
contractors and be it further ordered
that the city man to be and hereby is
requested to work with the board of the
Cambridge retirement system and other
appropriate city staff to ensure
divestment from all companies involved
in production of nuclear weapon systems
and it's entities investing in such
companies and that the city manager is
requested to report back to the City
Council about the implementation of said
divestment in a timely manner this was
put before the City Council on March
21st and was unanimously adopted
so just bit mayor simmons is too modest
to say how much much money this is how
successful cambridge is a city but this
is actually a fund that holds
approximately not 1 million but
approximately 1 billion dollars is what
they're talking about so that's really
walking the walk thank you and the
important thing to say is and I said it
in my early remarks is Cambridge is
saying resoundingly not in our name
thank you
so this is what political leadership
looks like people okay comments from the
group on where we are with the
divestment campaign where can we go from
Cambridge people ask questions don't the
mayor also first about this did like a
lot of the journalism questions maybe so
questions questions to the mayor on the
announcement she dismayed oz arena yeah
let's head let's have question people
come to the mic on go ahead Serena but
after after her everyone come to the mic
hmm I just wanna say thank you very much
can you hear me hold it right up to your
mouth uh so thank you very much and also
I wanted to know first of all how we can
get Boston to do this also as well as
can we get some universities to enact as
well as some Draper lab initiatives to
have more not in our name on campaign
going so first of all if you're going to
ask anyone to do something you should do
it yourself so I can't as a mirror
member and City Council say to MIT or
drape a lab or anyone else don't do this
if I'm not willing to do it myself or
ourselves so that's the very first stop
and because as a mayor I get the
advantage or the opportunity to go to
the african-american mayor's Association
the mass Municipal Association the
conference of mayors I can take this and
say this is what we've done in Cambridge
and I would like you to do it as an
organization but if not will you do it
as individuals will you do as
individuals and municipalities and in
your town meetings can you bring this
forward and see if you can adopt in a
lot of times that will happen and then
as we build that ground movement these
same municipalities and towns can go to
organizations like the National League
of Cities which is a trade association
for elected officials to go to get
information about various and sundry
issues you can then grow it from there
so starting with us and then trying to
spread it out and thank you for that
question
Mike's on both sides go ahead over there
no it's not can I be heard yeah okay
okay thank you okay thank you my name is
Ian Brinkley I'm an activist with the
LaRouche political action committee
thank you for the opportunity just
wanted to since the title of the panel
is mobilizing to reduce the dangers it
seems to me like one of the most
important things that we could do to
reduce the danger of nuclear war would
be to remove the current president of
the united states since number one he's
he is a war criminal he has engaged in
illegal wars and also mass murder
through the drone operations and right
now he is preparing us for a war with
Russia and China so it seems like we
should we should take steps to if we're
serious about peace we should take steps
to impeach him and and work with Russia
and China thank you that the mayor just
made and ask four questions on that
announcement please go ahead able um
well I just want to congratulate you I
made someone's on your leadership here
it's really been amazing I um sorry I
was just congratulating to mayor under
under leadership in this area and I just
wanted to quickly respond to a question
about campuses because you also asked
about that and I want to say to all just
because I know there a lot of students
in this audience that we actually have
research on college campuses as well so
I hope you know and we'll be in touch
with you I hope we can really work with
everyone to you know build on this
leadership that came which is really
provided here thanks and thanks again
for everything thank you a masterpiece
action that has really been turning the
corner on working working with
universities and call you can probably
talk a little bit about the work that
we've done
Harvard piece actions that he would be
the contact yeah and yes peace action
this year has formed chapters at seven
area campuses and five colleges into
high schools and we hope to further
expand next year and if you're a student
at let's see we have I think I saw Haley
over here from Tufts there she is and we
have a chapter at emmanuel college we
have a chapter forming just getting
started at Brandeis we have a chapter at
Holy Cross and then both Newton public
high schools and if you're a student at
another institution is katelyn still
here Caitlin is our campus organizing
lead and please see her if you innocent
getting started at peace action group
yes Erica fine with women's Action for
new directions I just want to say I'm
really inspired by this announcement it
gives me butterflies is somebody who
works on this issue in Washington that
really changes you know this kind of
leadership and change is possible quick
question is the legislation available
online yes it is onion if you go into
cambridge MA gov we have a new portal
where you can just click on that portal
first go to City Council then you'll say
open data portal you click on that
portal and then we go to the meeting of
what i say March 21st you'll see the
order there thank you hi oh wow that is
loud first off congratulations it's
amazing and I know that wasn't just your
efforts it was the efforts of a bunch of
people going to City Council and
presenting their case and so this was a
really collaborative effort so yay I'm
just wondering um I'm just wondering so
I live in Arlington which is a town not
a city so we don't have a council we
have a town meeting how can I apply as a
resident of a town this stuff you know
how can I spread this to a slightly
different operation if you will so any
citizens let me just use Cambridge for
an example so any citizen can bring
anything forward to the City Council
again
I don't know if I said thank you thank
you thank you too Lucas Perry and then
the professor tegmark because they
brought it to me and I said let's do
something about this and I did it by way
of a policy order so your town may work
that very same way you every most most
cities or towns have a way for citizen
participation it could so you either to
a citizen petition are going through
someone and that participates or serves
on time I don't know if it's called
selectmen in Arlington or what but going
to one of them and see if they will you
could you could bring this and say could
you model this very likely we will send
this across through the MMA and other
means to cities and towns for them to
get it but you yourself can take and and
say this is what they did in cambridge
can we do something similar also just
quick announcement Katherine Clark is on
our side so if you're in cd5 be happy
yes absolutely OD lugano paper and i am
with the woman International League for
Peace and Freedom USA so it's a great
news i can't have to let you and we
already put this announcement to the
city console of ann arbor michigan
hopefully maybe we can push them to
follow we also like very much don't bank
on the bomb of susie so thank you very
much for this conference is very
inspiring thank you
go ahead you have a question Oh will you
actually use some of the work from bank
not bomb in the efforts to figure out
what to divest from specifically well
you know we were again I'm gonna go back
to Lucas and there's others that know
far better than me they did sort of
guide my feet but I want may defer
absolutely we worked closely with Susie
Snyder started with her list and then
realized that in the u.s. things are
very opaque because it's very hard to
figure out exactly what mutual fund
Owens what so so we did a lot of very
boring nerdy legwork the counter stuff
we specialize in here at MIT to make it
really easy to understand that's what we
built that's why there's an app for that
now but basically this builds on this is
not competition a difference from don't
bank at bomb this is don't Bank on the
bomb made easy this is don't back up on
the app where you can put in your own
personal investment and do if you want
to do what Mayor Simmons said and find
out you might be surprised that you
yourself are investing in something you
might not want to do and then I'll pass
it on to miss this don't back up yeah
and I think what max is done what's done
here is something that's really amazing
we had a real gap because we didn't look
at these these specific funds like the
mutual funds we look at the group level
policy so we look at what is citibank
but i'll go to citibank funds we look at
tiaa-cref not as what is the social
choice fund social choice equity fund
and so it maxes max took the metadata we
had and parse it out and made it
actually much more usable for for people
looking for where their retirement fund
is because we go to the group level
that's that's where we're at so it's
been an amazing cooperation and and we
also we've talked a lot back and forth
about the the producing companies these
contractors and we work together to set
that up to make sure that you know we
check each other's research and so on
and so it's wonderful to see this kind
of cooperation and it's a model for a
lot of places so I just want to say my
super thanks as well
okay I don't see any more questions I'm
gonna ask one myself mayor Simmons yes
what are the steps from your
announcement today to actually moving
the money out of the pension fund so
what as the order says because we have a
city manager form of government we do
this order we have now directed the city
manager to convene two processes one to
go to the campus Retirement Board sit
them down and say where is the Cambridge
retirement money's going and through
that process he has been now mandated
through this order to work toward taking
that money out to I mean stop investing
in those companies that's one and then
the second piece is that there be a
working group or group of people to try
to try to convene an opportunity for
citizens to come and do and hear what
you've said Susie I can have two
teleconference to you in or maybe we
should send for you but to have to have
ways for people to understand where they
their money is going personally so we're
going to look at it on the sort of large
retirement level but also as Susie as
pointed out to us we have to be a little
bit more vigilant and look ourselves
where our money we personally put our
own money so it's just two prongs but
the other thing I want to add to that is
in june i'll be going to the association
of mayors and i'm going to take this
order there and see they'll be taking
interest and picking it up either they
may not do it as a group but it can go
two ways they can either say yes we
think it's a great idea and take it on
or they may at least I'll be armed with
it say this is something I want to take
up in my city or town great and now let
me ask the same question to max max is
the originator of don't Bank on the bomb
us if that's the right label what do you
see as the next steps in our campaign Oh
first of all I don't feel that there's a
bank on the bomb us versus Europe
whatever we're all together there's only
one unit unified goal here we want to
reduce the risk of nuclear war by not
fueling it but by investing in things
that just make us less safe and we're
all we're simply working together to
help each other out the next steps well
first of all please try this app and
you'll undoubtedly come up with a lot of
ideas for how this can be made better
email me and Lucas about that and though
will be our next steps we already know
about a lot of things that are
embarrassing lame about this and we're
working very hard but you will
undoubtedly come up with more things and
we want to make it as easy as possible
for people to actually do it and keep
the ideas coming and keep us busy Eileen
just all that you know it look very
closely what's happening with it with a
fossil fuel divestment because we work
in partnership in a lot of countries
with people who are getting divestment
to happen from fossil fuels you get a
win on something you kind of want to
keep winning and and why not right why
not deal with another existential threat
uh-huh and so there are good resources
on 350.org and on divest invest dot org
that both give you options for where you
can where you can put your money if
you're talking fossil fuels and really
happy that you know these are these are
folks that that have made this
information available and you know it's
also it's great when you see something
like Bloomberg financial press talking
about how important it is that you get
good sustainable economic returns by
taking your money out of inhumane
industries so you want to make money and
take our money away from inhumane
industry Hey sounds like a win-win
mm-hmm ok Joseph you'll get the last
question a question in a comment I know
we're a secular institution here but how
many people belong to religious
congregations in the room so you should
assume that your religious denomination
has a lot of money invested in pensions
and banks and otherwise and so the
number of us are beginning to explore
how we begin a process of raising the
process through the religious
denominations which is also a way which
we can do kind of mass education and
stigmatization so simply keep this in
mind and you'll be looking to
to the web pages and and the resources
that will come available great thank you
ok well let's break now and we'll take a
five-minute break before we begin the
next panel which is current prospects
for progress